marioupol tout près de la frontière on
retrouve sur place notre envoyé spécial
julien shade à julien bonjour une
première question est évidemment on
vient de voir le sentiment d'aider
ukrainien à kiev quel est le ressenti la
population là vous vous trouvez
aujourd'hui
est bien le ressenti c'est simple c'est
une énorme sidération après les propos
très agressif hier soir de vladimir
poutine les gens à qui on a pu parler
depuis que nous sommes arrivés ici à
marioupol nous ont aussi fait part de
leur peur ils ne le cachent pas ils ont
très peur à cause de l'ordre donné par
le chef du kremlin à l'armée russe
devenir officiellement maintenant la
paix dans le donbass les gens ici
craignent que les militaires russes ne
vienne jusqu'à marioupol on se trouve à
peu près à 20 km de la ligne de front
mais pour lui il faut préciser qu'il
n'ya pas de sentiment de panique dans la
ville les gens ont peur mais pour
l'instant il reste serein ils disent
préfère attendre de voir comment les
choses vont évoluer dans les prochains
jours et il n'est absolument pas
question de quitter la ville et pour
certains il n'est pas question de fuir
tout simplement parce qu'ils n'ont nulle
part où aller nous ont-ils dit cette
région pour l'instant a été relativement
épargnée depuis le regain de tension
mais la perspective d'une arrivée des
russes ici dans la ville réveille de
mauvais souvenir puisque lorsque la
guerre civile avait débuté en 2014 la
ville avait été prise très peu de temps
aux mains des pro romain départ les
séparatistes pro russes avant que
l'armée ukrainienne ne les délogent
d'ici à l'heure où boris johnson chef du
gouvernement britannique est en train de
dénoncer un prétexte à une offensive
d'envergure marioupol c'est une ville
stratégique julien il y avait déjà eu
des affrontements on s'en souvient en
2014 faut-il
pensez que c'est la prochaine cible
en tout cas c'est ce que disent certains
analystes c'est une ville extrêmement
symbolique pourquoi parce que mario paul
c'est la plus grande ville à l'est c'est
la dernière ville à l'est puis encore
sous contrôle le diana grandes villes
pardon à l'aise quittant contrôle encore
sous contrôle l'ukrainien c'est une
ville qui compte environ 450 milles
habitants et vous pouvez le voir
derrière moi c'est une ville qui habite
à très grand port industriel d'un des
plus grands du pays c'est aussi ici que
sont construits des navires commerciaux
donc vous le voyez poumon économique
pour symbole pour le gouvernement
ukrainien et c'est aussi à une prise
possible pour les russes sur le plan
militaire pourquoi et bien parce que si
vous regardez sur une carte mario paul
se situe entre d'un côté à l'est la
région du donbass et au sud la crimée a
annexé par la russie en 2014 et si la
russie venait à prendre mario paul elle
pourrait du coup selon les experts
contrôler toute la mer d'azov merci
beaucoup julien chez id ans